don't want the summer to end sport what
so i can go back to my
normal boring life in total normal
boring bellwood
oh hey it finally happened
now i can buy the t-rated games grandpa
max
let's go to a pg-13 movie with adult
situations and some coarse language
my goodness just look at the time this
review requested on my patreon by jaden
lips
feel free to donate if you want to help
support the channel ben 10 is a show
near and dear to my heart
with humble beginnings on cartoon
network in 2005
i watched the series premiere one night
and have been hooked ever since the
series is about an ordinary 10 year old
boy who discovers an
alien device called the omnitrix that
allows him to transform into 10
different alien species
each with their own superpower that he
can use to fight crime
it's had a complicated history since
then becoming a massive franchise and
going through a lot of different
iterations and reinventions
but for now i just want to go back to
the very beginning and outline what made
this show resonate with kids like me so
much
and why i think it's one of the most
enduring and successful superhero
franchises to not bear the mark of
marvel or dc
but in short i think the answer is that
ben 10 is the best superhero that
didn't come from comic books the show
has everything it needs to be a perfect
superhero story
[Music]
but first a word from our sponsor thanks
to smart dns proxy for sponsoring this
video
as the number one smart dns provider in
the world it unblocks and provides
access to disney plus
hbo hulu us netflix and hundreds of
other us streaming services around the
world
also people from the us can benefit from
accessing other countries streaming
services
smart dns proxy has two main services
for its users
smart dns a dns service that
automatically routes devices to proper
networks to unblock the channels on
almost any device
including computers mobile devices media
players like apple tv
roku and smart tv it's easy to set up
users just need to change dns to smart
dns proxy server and that's it
it's also free to sign up and try their
dns for two weeks smart vpn
the only vpn solution in the world that
combines vpn and smart dns solutions at
once
their smart vpn servers encrypt users
internet traffic and secures them from
government monitoring
hackers and other prying eyes also their
smart vpn server provides access to 600
channels like no other vpn can
so users can connect to any of the smart
vpn servers around the world
encrypt their traffic and stream from
their favorite channels around the world
all at the same time
the smart vpn network also has torrent
supported servers so users can do
all of the above and download torrents
safely to get a 50
discount for the first two weeks use the
referral link in the description
this series gave us kids so much to get
excited for back in the day
explosive stories giant monsters crazy
world building and lore
and of course some shockingly violent
fight scenes for a kid's cartoon
they really beat each other's asses in
this show but it wasn't all just
violence and monsters
this show had a lot of heart and
creativity that kids could really
respond to
starting with a really unique story that
unfolds in an interesting way
season 1 has a really great origin arc
where our hero timmy turner uchiha gets
his hands on some superpowers during
summer vacation with his cousin
and his grandpa on a cross-country road
trip ben tennyson is a brash
hot-headed overconfident kid with a
bratty sense of humor
but deep down he's actually very noble
and willing to heroically stand up for
the little guy
now fork over the cash so we can get out
of here
leave him alone
thanks a lot his cousin gwen is bookish
responsible and self-reliant
and their conflicting personalities lead
them to arguing a lot because you know
that's what kids do
what is she doing here take it easy
dweeb this wasn't my idea
please tell me you didn't even when i
was a kid i found some of their banter
kind of cringy or forced but i suppose
that's the point considering their age
it's nice seeing them eventually start
to get along their grandpa
max tennyson is just a wholesome sweet
guy that's intelligent
well traveled and likes nature geek jerk
something tells me it's gonna be a long
summer
marinated meal worms hard to find them
fresh in the states
you know they're considered a delicacy
in some countries
he's got a real uncle ben feel to him
but he doesn't get tragically killed off
to make the main character feel bad
he's the kind of parental figure that
you'd never want to disappoint like my
dad
optimus prime subscribe to xavier for
more videos like this one
during a freak accident where a pod from
space permanently attaches a piece of
alien technology to his wrist
ben gets the ability to turn into
various extraterrestrial monsters and
cause chaos while being attacked by bad
guys from earth and space
it's on the theme song you know how it
goes
also jacob is here for some reason hi
hello
let's count them down boy and then there
were ten
venom but for transformers fast
nightmare wrapped in skin swamp ass
hornet
diamonds are a girl's best friend d
bradley baker's famous snarls
waking up in the middle of the night and
chugging the closest liquid
[Music]
this species aging makes no sense
because no one kept continuity
and what do you get when you cross a
volcano with a voice that's as cool as
ice
check it out i'm totally hot
i think he's gonna stay a monster
forever he's not a monster
he's an alien i i mean
look at him what else could he be
instantly it seems like grandpa max
knows more than he's letting on but they
let that simmer for a few episodes as we
expand on our story
with time we learned that the watch
ended up on earth because it was being
kept away from an alien warlord who
looks oddly similar to the bad guy from
magus xlr
known as vilgax you hold the key to a
power struggle
so ancient so vast
it is beyond your feeble comprehension
i don't know why but that name is just
really perfect you know
some guys just look like a todd or or a
mic
this guy just looks like a vilgax i look
at him and vilgax is the word that pops
into my head
so he wants to use the device's power to
take over the universe
but in chasing it he gets a little
messed up and can't retrieve it directly
yet
that gives us time for ben to discover
all 10 alien forms in the watch
and stop some more low stakes super
crime but when vilgax finally steps in
he's a really imposing and badass
villain
and as overpowered as ben may seem he's
still pretty outclassed against this
tall angry squidman
after a crazy season 1 finale we
discover grandpa max's secret past
as an alien hunting superhero of sorts
that has protected earth with advanced
weaponry for decades
his organization was codenamed the
plumbers
for some reason he's actually vilgax's
old nemesis and the two of them
battled ages ago when vilgax's fashion
sense was a little more rocky horror
picture show than his current attire
it was big at the time grandpa max's
alien belt notches also apparently rival
that of the great captain kirk or
commander shepard
who would have thunk a standout feature
of this show is the voice acting
okay animal science class is cancelled
what are you doing uh looking for the
gold sumo slammer card
duh you're supposed to use your powers
to help people
not find some stupid trading card i love
the voices for all the aliens
particularly steve bloom is all these
ones and is the main villain of the
series
but each classic alien has so much
personality to its design and powers
every kid on the block wanted this watch
for themselves and would argue about
which alien transformation was the best
one
or which one they wanted an action
figure of the most i remember my cousin
was more of a forearms kind of guy
but i was partial to heat blast everyone
has their own favorite and each one can
be useful
with the exception of rip jaws the fish
guy i feel like they could only use him
by specifically writing episodes around
bodies of water as a plot device or by
making him an inconvenient one to turn
into to increase the stakes
ben's powers are so interesting because
he basically has every super power
granted with some heavy limitations to
keep him from being too op
but it's all there and of course that
was a smart idea because you just
decoupled the amount of action figures
you could sell for one character without
any of them being lame repaints of the
same mold
look it up that's a word i think i was
however always disappointed with the
toys based on the omnitrix as a kid
they were fine but never accurate enough
for my tastes i really wish someone
online would make a great hyper accurate
prop of this thing for cosplays or
just to have as a collectible even just
a fan made thing would work for me
all i could find was this one on etsy
and the dial is facing the wrong way and
i don't like how the faceplate is shaped
someone with a 3d printer or better prop
making skills than myself please get on
that
ideally cartoon network will just
capitalize on the idea and make like a
200
official one with a smartwatch built
into it to simulate the screen
but i don't think they care that much
much like any good superhero
ben even has a built-in weakness to keep
things interesting his watch has a timer
on it that runs out after he's been
transformed for 10 minutes well
10 minutes in canon but for the sake of
compressing time for a 22 minute cartoon
it actually runs on the same timetable
as how long it takes spider-man to run
out of webs
which is exactly as long as the writer
wants until the precise moment when it's
most inconvenient
and dramatically exciting ben also has a
habit of tampering with the thing
because he's irresponsible and kind of a
bart simpson type
so it's a running gag that he's in
possession of the most dangerous
technology in the universe and sometimes
he just smashes it against the walls or
jams a screwdriver into it or uses it to
break walnuts or whatever
and it causes the thing to work
improperly by not turning into the alien
he selected
or just glitch out and not let him
change back to a human for an extended
period of time
we got company closing in fast
that gives a nice bit of added tension
because sometimes you think one guy is
the obvious solution to a problem
but the watch gives him another one and
he has to figure out how to make do with
that instead
time to go
oh forearms watch shows how resourceful
he can be in a pinch
and for all his trash talk he's actually
pretty smart
he's a cool character once you look past
all his surface level attitude problems
along the way his constant button
mashing allows him to unlock additional
aliens to turn into
with some cool new powers and gimmicks
meaning there's a lot more than just 10
in there
more like thousands upon thousands
you know if you mess with the settings
on this thing long enough
you can turn into some really crazy
stuff
[Music]
uh
huh for some reason my voice doesn't
change for this one
we also meet a few good guy aliens to
help ben grow as a character
like an alien mercenary named tetrax
that donated some of his own dna to the
watch
allowing ben to turn into him he teaches
him to use some more clever tactics and
to think his way through a fight more
often
instead of just turning into the
muscular guys over and over we even meet
the sarcastic little alien scientist who
built the watch in the show's first tv
movie
the creator azimuth explains that it's
not a weapon for war but a tool to
create understanding and racial peace
between alien cultures across the
universe
by allowing species to walk a mile in
each other's shoes that's a pretty heavy
concept for a kids show
feels more like an idea out of a random
star trek episode
i love that the show didn't pull punches
on something nuanced like that
so with the reveal that their grandpa is
an xg man and knows pretty much all
there is to know about the omnitrix and
the various criminal entities in the
universe who want to get their hands on
it
the show opens up so much more in season
two i'd also like to take time to
highlight how much i love this show's
other greatest villain
kevin e levin
hmm i know the name is a little on the
nose but if vilgax is norman osborne
then this kid is the venom of this show
he's a vandal punk kid that lives on the
streets with super powers of his own
the ability to absorb and expel energy
like a human battery
ben runs into him and they become fast
friends using their powers to act like a
couple of schmucks and perform some good
old-fashioned b and e to get an
unreleased video game
before outrunning the cops but kevin
turns out to be a little bit of a loose
cannon and wants to start using their
powers for more extreme crimes than
stealing video games
him and ben battle it out we discover
that kevin can use his powers to absorb
the energy from the omnitrix and take on
some of ben's powers
he's a morally bankrupt dark reflection
of our hero
they have multiple battles with kevin
mimicking ben's aliens before he goes
too far and becomes this hodgepodge of
all of
[Music]
this them at what you've done it's
payback talent for turning me into a
free
you're all he's a freak kevin it's just
now the uglies also on the outside
i'm still ten times better than you i've
got all your powers
plus my own i'm kevin 11. this is a
weird note but i've always wished
carnage sounded like this voice actor
with this filter
something about that seems really right
they even have a great episode in season
two where ben and kevin get stuck in an
alien gladiator arena with an electric
shock button attached to them
and they have to work together to escape
is this just planet hulk
they came out around the same time weird
the other strongest villain characters
would have to be dr animo and
charmcaster
one's a mad scientist that uses animal
dna to create
giant monsters and the other is a young
sorceress that's trying to live up to
her evil uncle's name as a magic villain
i typically don't care for the human
villains in this series but these two
stand out a lot more than
say the forever knights those guys are
like an evil version of the plumbers and
want to hunt and experiment on
all aliens not just the bad ones in
concept they could be cool but i felt
like they were more of an excuse to have
generic stormtrooper type bad guys that
we could just punch a thousand of
season two ends with a banger of an
episode where vilgax and kevin team up
to kill ben
but he's accidentally turned off all the
restrictions on the watch and he can
change into any of the aliens with a
thought
for however long he wants it's awesome
to see him really let loose to keep up
with his two greatest enemies
and he ends up ditching them in an
alternate universe called the null void
that grandpa max used to drop
dangerous alien criminals into my head
canon is that the null void
the phantom zone and the negative zone
are all the same place and people all
over the multiverse just keep opening
portals to it to dump their trash
going ghost dragging up shazam
i'll put a shock to your system so
what's this itch
shotting gun titans go i'm the best
there isn't what i do
bob season three and four afterwards
feel a little directionless with the two
main villains gone
and they spend the next few episodes
just roaming around the continental us
riding wrongs and fighting random
smaller antagonists
but the majority of them aren't as
interesting as darth cthulu and
frankenstein's alien
the exception probably being this guy
yeah i know ben's supposed to be that
guy right well they always plan the idea
for one of the aliens in the watch
ghost freak being a criminal who regains
his consciousness and wants to escape
he's pretty cool initially other than
that not a whole lot of important stuff
happens for the last two seasons
they continually introduce more and more
transformations but they just don't feel
as special or as engaging to me as the
original set
back in the day i just didn't vibe with
some of these season 3 editions because
they felt kind of lazy by just sticking
with this boo haunted house theme
like this one is a werewolf this one is
a mummy
this one is a frankenstein's monster oh
brother ditto and upchuck are cool
though
they also really don't know what to do
with ben's cousin gwen
so to keep her from feeling like too
much of a sidekick they bring in this
story where she starts learning magic
from a spell book they pilfered from
charm caster
this choice seemed a little weird to me
in a show that was so heavily steeped in
sci-fi and it gave me the sense they
just threw it in there to give her
something to do during the fight scenes
since everyone else was so proactive
it's not the worst idea in the world and
it's paid off in the later shows
very well but here it wasn't fully
thought out yet
this summer road trip feels like it
lasts way longer than three months
in fact this is the second longest
cartoon summer vacation after phineas
and ferb
these last two seasons i don't feel as
invested in the villains but i really
enjoy the smaller one-off episodes that
feel more
slice of life couple examples ben's
older cousin another member of the
plumbers
marries an alien from a race that humans
have been at war with for decades
there's this interesting family rivalry
where everyone wants to stop the wedding
and ben has to make sure it happens to
form a bond of peace between the two
species there's also a really neat
episode where ben and gwen are taken to
a possible future
where ben has become the greatest
superhero in the universe by the time
he's 30
but as a result of doing this for so
long he's become jaded and serious
never leaving his alien forms but
meeting his younger self gives him a
reality check and helps him learn to
have some fun and appreciate his human
half once again
it's like that bruce willis movie but
with aliens this future is super not
canon but it's a fun glimpse into what
ben's life could have been like
season 3 and 4 remind me of the last few
issues of a really great comic run after
the writer has finished their main
overarching story and just spends a
little extra time with the characters
doing smaller things for another
5-10 issues before the new writer steps
in to mix things up
this show definitely has the
fingerprints of comic industry writers
all over it like that it even has a few
alternate universe what if episodes
where gwen gets the watch in an
alternate timeline or a story where
ben's parents find out about his powers
after the summer ends
[Music]
ben is it just me or are those super
lame-o versions of your alien heroes
as with any other long-running story
it's fun to go back to the earliest
stuff and look at it with the
perspective of future context
she can do this because she has the
recessive genes of their alien grandma
who's a being of pure energy that can
warp reality with her thoughts
making her kind of a god
that rock fell because his 17 year old
self from the future was standing behind
a tree nearby and made the ground shake
so he'd find the watch and ensure the
timeline happened
that guy ages backwards apparently
that guy's gonna get super buff
these two characters start dating in
high school and this kid from ben's
school will get a robot arm and try to
kill him in a parking lot when they're
15.
eventually this show winds down with an
hour-long special where he faces off
against 10 of his human antagonists from
throughout the show as a nice little
closer
there was also a live action tv movie
that was
um it was
uh i liked it when i was eight years old
and i had a block party song in the
trailer and they're one of my favorite
bands so that was cool hey wait a minute
why is that logo have a little triangle
on it in that graphic
that's not how it looks oh my god the
trailer company must have gotten
confused by the toy
because it has this opening on it
instead of the screen
how does that happen the movie is
cute i guess but didn't live up to the
expectations of the series because of
its confusing story and low budget
effects
it also didn't help that the alien voice
actors from the show didn't make it in
either
uh this is the part where you tell me
your name what your evil intentions are
you have done this before right gym
class is in
session today we play funnel the creepy
alien dude
gt and cash are gonna get theirs
that doesn't sound like invader zim ben
10 is a great series that got my
imagination
really flowing as a kid because it was
so good at thinking outside of the box
and doing something unique
but still very classic for a superhero
show it has all the hallmarks of a great
comic book character
without ever being based on a comic book
and you must be
batman just kidding can i have your
autograph
you want my autograph i mean
yes of course it's a great mix of
original ideas
and taking inspiration from other
sources to make something new and fresh
ben as a character is great because he's
relatable for kids
but even at that age his flaws are still
identifiable and it was inspiring to see
him overcome them
and grow past them through the course of
the series he was a character that
taught us that brains can beat brawn
that you should always do the right
thing even with nearly infinite power
and that family is an even greater power
than that much like ben
himself it isn't a perfect show but it
stuck with us and became something that
we could all see a bit of ourselves in
it inspired us that's a perfect
superhero story to me
hey there viewers from earth and
otherwise ben dennison here doing my
best impression of the
out of the world talent yuri lowenthal
be sure to subscribe to xavier for more
videos like this one
see you next time tell me who your
favorite alien is in the comments and
why any answer other than heat blast and
ghost freak is incorrect
thanks again to jacob corpus for helping
me animate this video and of course
ben 10 himself yuri lowenthal for being
a guest in this video
you're the best
[Music]
[Music]
you